This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字 TWO 点。可在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在 Look Back at it 播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在进行这些对话。多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 learn the hard way。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeart radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode, as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I hope you all had a transformative fun but safe start to the new year. Welcome to 2025. Before we get into this episode, a few months back, I said that I had a lot of surprises in store for this year.
欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们一如既往地剖析我们的20岁心理学。我希望你们都有一个充满变革、有趣但安全的新年开端。欢迎来到2025年。在我们进入这期节目之前，几个月前，我说过我今年有很多惊喜在等着大家。
And guess what? You did not have to wait long for the first one. And probably one of the biggest ones. I am so beyond excited to announce that my brand new podcast, mantra. We'll be launching on the 13th of January. Yes, you heard me write a brand new podcast. And if you are a fan of the psychology of your 20s, you're going to love this if you're interested in expanding your mind, improving your mindset, growing as a person, learning. Mantra is going to be the perfect fit for you. Every Monday, I focus on a new mantra so you can begin
你猜怎么着？你不用等太久就能迎来第一个惊喜。而且可能是最大的惊喜之一。我无比激动地宣布，我的全新播客节目《mantra》将于1月13日上线。是的，你没听错，这是一个全新的播客。如果你是《你的20岁心理学》的粉丝，如果你对拓展思维、改善心态、个人成长和学习感兴趣，你会爱上这个节目的。《mantra》将是你的完美选择。每周一，我都会专注于一个新的人生箴言，这样你就可以开始
your week with a mental reset and I talk to you about the meaning of the mantra, how to really take advantage of what that mantra can do for you, where we can see it show up in our lives and also journal prompts, a weekly challenge. We have been working so hard on this. And the reason I really wanted to do a show like this is because I love the psychology of your 20s is of course my creative baby. But I also wanted to have a space that isn't just the science. It's more inspirational and reaffirming, perhaps even more spiritual, which is also an important part of who I am, along with my love of humans and numbers and studies and the psychology of things. And mantra just felt like the perfect way to do this. Every Monday is a mental
通过精神重置来开启你的一周，我将和你探讨这个箴言的含义，如何真正利用这个箴言能为你带来的益处，我们在哪里可以看到它在生活中显现，以及日记提示和每周挑战。我们为这个节目付出了极大的努力。我之所以真正想做这样一个节目，是因为我热爱《你的20岁心理学》，这当然是我的创意结晶。但我也希望有一个不仅仅关乎科学的空间。它更具启发性和肯定性，甚至可能更具精神性，这也是我的一部分重要组成部分，伴随着我对人类、数字、研究以及事物心理学的热爱。而《mantra》感觉就是完美的实现方式。每周一都是一次心灵的
reset. You tune in on your morning commute, when you're at work, when you're at the gym, and it just sets the tone for the rest of your week. You can be one of the first people to hear it and listen to the brand new episode. If you subscribe to Mantra now on Spotify or Apple Podcasts, it's already up there. It's ready to go. The first episode drops in less than a week. I hope you love it. I really, really do.
重置。你在早晨通勤时、在工作时、在健身房时收听，它为你的其余一周定下了基调。你可以成为第一批听到并收听全新一集的人之一。如果你现在在 Spotify 或 Apple Podcasts 上订阅 Mantra，它已经在那里了。已经准备就绪。第一集将在不到一周内发布。希望你会喜欢。我是真的，真的很喜欢。
It is just such a passion project for me, something I think is going to be such an important thing to put out into the world, hopefully make a huge difference. Hopefully just inspire you, give you more things to listen to. if you need a new podcast, there it is. Without further ado, though, let's talk about the psychology of manifestation, which is, of course, today's topic. One that I have been really excited to do for a while, actually. It's very much been at the top of the list, but just keeps getting bumped down by things
这对我来说是一个充满热情的项目，我认为这是一件非常重要的事情，可以带给世界，希望能带来巨大的改变。希望只是启发你，为你提供更多可听的内容。如果你需要一个新播客，就是这个。不过，闲话少说，让我们来谈谈显化心理学，这当然是今天的话题。实际上，我一直非常期待做这个主题。它一直排在清单的最顶部，但总是被那些感觉更重要的东西给挤下去了。但这是一个崭新的一年，这感觉是一个绝佳的切入点，可以直接深入探讨的节目。所以，如果你对显化完全陌生，我会给你做一个简短的入门介绍。显化是一个非常肯定、意义重大的理念，即你可以通过你的思想吸引你的梦想生活。你看待情况的方式很重要，这是实现你最大愿望的有力方式。所以基本上，如果我们想积极的事情，积极的事情就会发生。如果我们认为自己很幸运，幸运的事情就会降临到我们身上。
that felt more important. But it's a brand new year, and this just felt like a great episode to dive into straight off the bat. So if you are brand new to manifestation, I'll give you a quick 101. Manifesting is this very affirming, significant idea that you can attract your dream life by using your thoughts. How you view a situation matters and it's a powerful way to bring about your greatest desires. So basically, if we think positive things, they will happen. If we think we are lucky, lucky things will happen to us.
这就是整个前提，而显化在近年来变得如此惊人的流行，特别是在一本名为《秘密》的书取得成功之后，它实际上是由一位澳大利亚作家在2006年撰写的，它重新引入了这个古老的理念：你的思想是你想要的现实的强大磁铁。这个前提在许多文化中当然已经存在了数千年，这一点很重要承认。例如，佛陀教导说，我们的思想塑造了我们，我们的意图决定了我们的命运。所以这绝对不是一个新概念，但它是一个非常强大的概念，已经触及了全新的一批受众。如果这听起来好得令人难以置信，我理解你。我完全理解。特别是如果你是一个像我一样相当
that is the whole premise and manifesting it's become so incredibly popular in recent years specifically after the success of a book called The Secret actually was written by an Australian author back in 2006 and it reintroduced this ancient idea that your thoughts are a powerful magnet for the reality that you want that premise has of course existed in a number of cultures for thousands of years, it's important to acknowledge that. Buddha, for example, taught that our thoughts shape us and that our intentions determine our destinies. So it's definitely not a new idea, but it's a very powerful one that has reached a whole new audience. If it sounds too good to be true, I get you. I totally understand. Especially if you're someone who is quite
科学的人，任何提供简单、快速修复、轻松解决生活方案、让一切皆有可能、你知道的，赚到一百万美元的东西，听起来都像是个骗局。此外，我们确实不得不讨论显化对于那些经历贫困、饥饿或战争的人来说有时显得多么精英主义，对他们来说，积极的想法很可能无法改变更大的系统性问题。对显化确实有一些批评。它绝对有一些重大问题。
scientific like me, anything that offers a simple, quick fix, easy solution to transform your life, to make everything possible to, you know, make a million dollars. Sounds like a scam. Additionally, we do really have to talk about how elitist manifestation can sometimes seem for people who are experiencing poverty or starvation or war for whom thinking positive things will most likely not change a larger systemic problem. There are some criticisms of manifestation. It's definitely got some major issues.
我们稍后会讨论这一点，但我也真的很想为你剖析它，并展示它不仅仅是一个神奇、神秘的概念，对于那些成功实施显化的人来说，很大程度上它确实植根于心理学、我们的认知、潜意识，以及我们的信念和心态如何潜移默化地控制我们的行动和行为。你知道，如果你真的相信某事会发生，并且你有能力和资源去付诸行动，这至关重要。这确实创造了一个自我实现的预言，让你更有可能以确保它发生的方式行事，即使你没有意识到这一点。
We're going to talk about that later on, but I also really want to break. it down for you and show that it's not just a magical, mystical idea for the people who successfully implement manifestation, a lot of it is really rooted in psychology and in our cognition and in our subconscious minds and how our beliefs and our mindset subliminally control our actions and our behaviors. You know, if you really believe something will happen to you and you have the ability and the resources to action that belief, that's crucial. It does create a self-fulfilling prophecy where you are more likely to act in a way that ensures that it will, even if you don't realize it.
你知道，很明显，如果你认为某事会发生却什么都不做，显化对你永远不会起作用。如果你想，是的，变富就好了，然后坐在那里无所事事地等待它发生，那不是显化运作的方式。这个非常合法的自助实践背后，有一些非常强大的心理学和神经科学支撑，
You know, obviously, if you think something will happen and you don't do anything about it, manifesting will never work for you. If you think, yeah, it would be nice to be rich and then just sit twiddling your thumbs waiting for it to happen, that's not how manifestation works. There is some really powerful psychology and neuroscience behind this very legitimate self-help practice
能够激发以目标为导向的行动。它真正依赖于从认知重构到自我对话的力量、自信的力量，以及诸如长期增强作用等神经学概念。所以今天，我想谈谈它，无论你是处于观望状态，还是完全致力于这个理念，或者你只是想提升并改善你显化的方式。这集节目就是为你准备的。本期节目有太多的科学知识、太多的迷人研究要涵盖。我还想根据所有这些心理学提供五个最强大的显化练习。在简短的休息之后，将为你呈现所有这些以及更多精彩内容。
that can spur on goal-directed, action. And it really relies on things from cognitive restructuring to the power of self-talk, the power of self-belief, and concepts, neurological concepts like long-term potentiation. So today, I want to talk about it if you're on the fence, if you're completely committed to the idea, if you're just trying to level up and improve the way you manifest. This episode is for you. There is so much science, so much fascinating research to cover in this episode. And I also want to provide the five most powerful manifestation exercises that you can use based on all this psychology. So all of that and so much more, it is a jam-packed episode after this short break.
近年来，显化在自助健康领域确实迎来了它的高光时刻。我不知道我是什么时候真正开始意识到显化这个概念的，但当我意识到时，我必须承认，我觉得这太荒谬了。你知道，你的思想怎么可能神奇地为你带来任何东西呢？你知道，我每天都有成千上万、数百万个想法。其中极少数能成为现实。我认为这绝对也归结于我有点像个过于追求卓越的人。你知道，我真的相信血汗泪和努力工作的绝对力量。
Manifestation has definitely been having a moment in the self-help wellness space in recent years. I don't know when I first really became aware of manifesting as a concept, but when I did, I will admit, I thought it was ridiculous. you know, how could your thoughts make anything magically happen for you? You know, I have thousands, millions of thoughts every day. Very few of them ever come true. I think that definitely came down to being a bit of an overachiever as well. You know, I really believed in the absolute power of blood, sweat and tears and hard work.
真的，那就是我的，这就是我的公式。你努力工作，你就能得到你为之努力和应得的东西。但在2019年，我真的第一次意识到我在生活中显化了某些事情。我经历了一次分手。我，你知道，真的致力于对自己重复所有这些积极的陈述。我在写日记，记录我在接下来的一个月、三个月、一年里想要什么。奇怪的是，很多都变成了现实。当我在调查时，我在想，哇，为什么会这样？你知道，这不可能全靠运气。
Really, that was my, like, that's my equation. You work hard, you get what you work for and what you deserve. But in 2019, I really had my first instance of kind of realizing that I had manifested certain things in my life. I'd gone through a breakup. I was, you know, really committed to repeating all these positive statements to myself. I was journaling about what I wanted in the next month, three months year. And strangely, a lot of it was coming true. And when I was investigating and I was like, wow, why is this happening? You know, it can't just all be luck.
我想这真的归结于这些实践如何重构和转变了我的思维对问题的看法。好吧，我已经扯远了。让我们收回思绪一会儿。让我们来谈谈显化的支柱，最常见的显化技术、主题，基本上就是这样。所以关于显化最大的正式理论无疑是吸引力法则。吸引力法则，你一定到处都听过。
And I think it really came down to how these practices were, restructuring and shifting how my mind thought about problems. Okay, I've already gone off on a tangent. Let's dial it back for a second. Let's talk about the pillars of manifestation, the most common manifestation techniques, themes, topics, basically. So the biggest formal theory of manifestation is undoubtedly the law of attraction. Law of attraction, you would have heard it everywhere.
而这个法则基本上表明，你的思想和信念可以把人、事件和环境吸引到你的生活中。它很大程度上基于这样一种观点，即人和他们的思想是由纯能量组成的，同类能量、相似的能量会吸引相似的能量，从而使我们能够通过思考积极的事情并将这些积极的事情吸引到我们身边，来改善我们的健康、财富或个人关系。所以基本上你的思想是一块磁铁。它们会吸引你认为你渴望的、你所想的任何东西。
And this law basically suggests that your thoughts and beliefs can attract people, events and circumstances into your life. And it's very much based on the idea that people and their thoughts are made up of pure energy and like energy, similar energy attracts similar energy, thereby allowing us to improve our health, wealth or personal relationships by thinking positive things and attracting those positive things to us. So basically your thoughts are a magnet. They attract whatever you think you desire that you think of.
以及你所关注的。另一种非常著名的显化形式当然是疏离法则（或超然法则）。这听起来像是吸引力法则的对立面，但它绝对不是完全矛盾的。它基本上表明，为了显化我们的愿望，我们必须释放对特定结果的执着。所以如果你正试图显化爱情，我知道这是一个很大的愿望，你需要抛弃爱情对你来说应该是什么样子的想法。
and that you focus on. Another very famous form of manifestation is, of course, the law of detachment. This sounds like the opposite of the law of attraction, but it's definitely not an entire contradiction. It basically suggests that in order to manifest our desires, we have to release our attachment to a specific outcome. So if you are trying to manifest love, I know that's a big one, you need to release the idea of what love could look like for you.
所以你不能一直期望爱情会是这样一个身高六尺四寸、深色头发、当律师、做着这些特定事情的人，他的名字叫安德鲁，27岁。就像你不能想象一个特定类型的人一样。你必须摆脱对你的愿望将如何降临到你身上的期望。就像结果会是什么样？你必须摆脱对特定结果的执着。对于一份（你知道的）梦想工作也是如此，如果你在显化你的梦想职业。你必须接受，也许你脑海中的并不合适，让我们假设宇宙或某种更高力量。这是很多人通常谈论的方式。
So you cannot keep expecting that love is going to be this six foot four dark-haired person who is a lawyer who does these exact specific things and their name is Andrew and they're 27. Like you can't imagine a specific kind of person. You have to detach from your expectations about how whatever your desire will come to you. Like what's the outcome going to be? You have to detach from a specific outcome. Same with a, you know, a dream job if you're manifesting your dream career. you have to accept that maybe what you have in mind isn't right and let let's say the universe or a higher power. That's how a lot of people normally talk about this.
你必须让它来指引你。所以我认为这在心理学基础上起作用的原因是，这种视角创造了内部转变，并使我们进入成长和好奇心的心态，这样我们以前可能没有关注过的机会现在对我们开放了，所以它让我们更加开放。我确实对疏离法则背后的前提有一些疑问，因为我认为，特别是对于焦虑的人或患有强迫症的人来说，从一个结果中脱离出来或打破一种思维模式可能是极其困难的，几乎是不可能的。
You have to let that guide you. So why I see this working on a psychological basis is that this perspective creates an internal shift and it puts us into a growth and curiosity mindset so that opportunities we may have previously not looked at now become available to us, so it keeps us more open. I definitely have some issues with the premise behind the law of detachment, because I think, especially for people who are anxious or who have anxiety or who have OCD, detaching from an outcome or breaking out of a thought pattern can be extremely hard, near impossible.
这并不意味着这些人仍然没有梦想成真。所以这个逻辑肯定有一些漏洞，对吧？过于焦虑的人并非只会遭遇坏事。你知道，吸引力法则的对立面。你知道，如果吸引力法则正确的话，思考消极的事情会让你遭遇消极的事情，一个过于焦虑的人，情况并非总是如此。所以回到吸引力法则，
That doesn't mean that these individuals don't still have dreams that come true. So there are certainly some holes in this logic, right? people who are overly anxious don't just have bad things happen to them as well. You know, the opposite of law of attraction. You know, if law of attraction is correct, you know, thinking about negative things would make negative things happen to you, someone who was overly anxious, that's not always the case. So moving back to the law of attraction,
因为我认为这确实是我们今天要聚焦的显化技术。如果你认为这仅仅是要求宇宙奖赏你，就像我曾经做的那样，我真的很想进一步解释那个心理学以及心理学解释。我们必须从这个非常基础的逻辑开始。相信你能完成某事，会让你比不相信时更有可能做到这一点。这取决于什么？它取决于自信的力量。自信，这是你在听过的任何成功故事中排名第一的巨大因素。
because I think that is really the manifestation technique that we're zoning in on today. If you think it's simply about asking the universe to reward you as I once did, I really want to explain further that psychology and that psychological explanation. And we have to start with this very fundamental logic. Believing that you can accomplish something is going to make it much more likely that you do compared to not believing. What does this rest on? It rests on the power of self-belief. Self-belief, that is the number one biggest factor in any success story that you will ever hear.
然而我认为这是被谈论最少的。如果你不相信成功会属于你，你就无法被激励。你无法自律。你无法承担风险。如果你不相信成功会属于你，你就无法对自己下注。所以不相信自己是一个以目标告终的矛盾。吸引力法则之所以奏效，以及许多人将显化视为开启他们不可思议生活的金钥匙的原因，是因为它改变了我们与自信相关的潜在潜意识、潜意识想法。
and yet I think it is the least talked about. You cannot be motivated. You cannot be disciplined. You cannot be a risk taker. You cannot bet on yourself if you do not believe that success will be yours. So not believing in yourself is a goal-ending contradiction. The reason that the law of attraction works and that many people see manifesting is a very golden key that unlocks this incredible life of theirs is, because of how it changes our underlying subconscious subliminal thoughts to do with self-belief.
这有一个别的名字。它被称为认知重构，你之前已经提到过好几次了。这是一个经过充分研究的、合法的治疗技术。基本上，这个方法让人们识别消极想法或自我限制的想法，并挑战它们，用更积极的想法取而代之。让我举个例子，说明如何使用美国心理学协会认可的认知重构或CBT五步法来做到这一点。首先，一个人确定他们想要改变的情境和感觉。例如，对未来的焦虑。
This is called by another name. It's called Cognitive Restructure, in which you've already mentioned a couple of times. It's a very well-researched, legitimate therapeutic technique. Basically, what this method has people do is identify negative thoughts or self-limiting thoughts and challenge them, replace them with more positive thoughts. So let me give you an example of how this could be used using the American Psychological Associations, a credited five-step process to cognitive restructuring or CBT. Firstly, a person identifies the situation and feeling that they would like to change. For example, let's say anxiety about the future.
这是我经常用于20多岁年轻人的一个例子。然后你确定这种感觉背后的潜在想法。例如，为什么我对未来感到焦虑？嗯，可能是因为，你知道，我不。确定。我害怕失败。我预料最坏的情况会发生。然后它要求人们在过去寻找这种情况的证据。所以你这里最糟糕的情况是什么？我会失败。我会很痛苦。我永远不会成功。我说这有何证据？谁跟你这么说的？水晶球在哪？然后它让你
It's one I always use for people in their 20s. Then you identify the underlying thoughts about the feeling. So for example, why am I feeling anxious about the future? Well, probably because, you know, I'm on. certain. I'm scared of failure. I expect the worst case scenario to happen. And then it asked people to look for evidence of that being the case in the past. So what is your worst case scenario here? I'm going to fail. I'm going to be miserable. I'm never going to find success. I say what's the evidence for that being the case? Who's telling you this? There's the magic ball. And then it gets you
真正专注于替代方案。如果最坏的情况没有发生呢？什么？如果最坏的情况没有发生呢？如果你成功了呢？为什么那不可能发生在你身上？如果一切对你都很顺利呢？然后他们要求你做一个决定，当未来再次出现这样的困境时，你是继续选择更有帮助的想法，还是继续选择帮助较小的想法？这通过改变与之相关的思维回路和路径，真正改变了我们的大脑对问题的反应方式。认知重构在某种程度上听起来很像显化。显化致力于为积极的结果创造更多的积极想法，而实际上，你知道，这需要将积极的场景引入你的大脑。认知重构听起来差不多。
to really focus on the alternative. What if the worst case scenario didn't happen? What? What if the worst case scenario didn't What if you were a success? Why couldn't that happen to you? What if it all worked out for you? Then they ask you to make a decision and when a future dilemma like this one comes up, do you continue to choose the more helpful thought or do you continue to choose the less helpful thought? This really changes how our brain responds to a problem by changing our thought circuits and pathways that are attached to it. cognitive restructuring sounds a lot like manifestation in that way. Manifestation is working to create more positive thoughts for a positive outcome, and really, you know, what that entails is introducing positive scenarios into your mind. Cognitive restructuring kind of sounds the same.
有很多证据表明这种技术是有效的。因此，2020年的一项研究调查了141名接受认知重构治疗的个人，发现经过12个月的随访，个人报告了较低的抑郁症状、较少的焦虑回避，而这才是真正重大的一点：更高的自我效能感。所以自我效能感，我们经常谈论它。它可能是我的概念之一，它基本上表明我们对自己实现想要的结果的能力的信念真的非常非常重要。所以自我效能感基本上就是你的自我效能感基本上就是你对实现未来、能够努力工作或保持一致性的信念。所以，你知道，
There is a lot of evidence for this kind of technique working. So there was a 2020 study that looked at 141 individuals who, received cognitive restructuring treatment, and it found that at a 12-month follow-up, individuals reported lower depressive symptoms, less anxious avoidance, and this is the really big one, greatest self-efficacy. So self-efficacy, we talk about it a lot. It's probably one of my favorite concepts, and it basically says that our belief in our ability to achieve an outcome that we want is really, really important. So self-efficacy is basically your self-efficacy is basically your belief in bringing about your future or being able to work hard or be consistent. So, you know,
如果你在工作中有个大项目或者你想开办一家公司，自我效能感高的人会说，是的，我有这个能力。这会很难，但我已经准备好迎接挑战了。我能做到。然而，如果你自我效能感低，你就会自我怀疑到无所作为，基本上是这样。幸运的是，自我效能感是你可以改变的，这也是做到这一点的一种方法，即认知重构。对显化心理学的另一种解释是我们非常熟知的自我实现预言。所以，当我们的信念和期望以将这些信念变为现实的方式影响我们的行动时，自我实现预言就发生了。因此，在显化的背景下，通过将成功或期望的结果可视化，我们在潜意识里将我们的
if you have a big project at work or you want to launch a business, people who are high in self-efficacy will say, yeah, I'm capable of that. It's going to be hard, but I'm ready for the challenge. I can do it. Whereas if you're low in self-efficacy, you'll doubt yourself into an inaction, basically. Luckily, self-efficacy is something that you can change and this is one way of doing it, that cognitive restructuring. Another explanation for the psychology of manifestation is what we know very commonly as a self-fulfilling prophecy. So a self-fulfilling prophecy occurs when our beliefs and expectations influence our actions in ways that bring those beliefs to life. So in the context of manifestation, by visualizing success or a desired outcome, we subconsciously align our
决策、态度和行动与该目标保持一致。这种专注确实提高了我们的动力、毅力和对那些我们以前可能忽视的机会的开放性。因此，本质上，显化利用了自我实现预言的心理机制，将积极的信念转化为刻意的行动，真正弥合了意图与成就之间的鸿沟。所以如果你走进一个房间，心里想，这个房间里的每个人都会爱上你，会认为你富有魅力、吸引力和诱惑力，你就会对自我感觉更好。因此，你会和更多的人说话。你会更加开放。你会进行更多的眼神交流。你会感觉
decisions, attitudes, and actions with that goal. This focus really increases our motivation, our perseverance, and our openness to those opportunities we might previously overlook. So, in essence, manifestation leverages the psychological mechanism of a self-fulfilling prophecy by turning positive beliefs into deliberate action, really bridging the gap between intention and achievement. So if you walk into a room, thinking, everyone in this room is going to fall in love with you, is going to think that you are charismatic and attractive and alluring, you are going to feel better about yourself. And so because of that, you'll probably speak to more people. You'll be more open. You'll make more eye contact. You'll feel
更好。你可能会走出去说，哦天哪，我把它显化出来了。这其实真的是一个自我实现预言。如果你想看到它的实际效果，你必须听听这个来自20世纪60年代的非常著名的实验，你以前可能听说过，但它是关于老师对学生的期望如何真正决定了他们的成绩以及表现最好的学生。而这实际上归结于那些戴眼镜的学生。因为老师们假设，你知道，如果你戴眼镜，你就会更聪明。所以他们就是这样对待他们的。他们对待他们就像他们已经很聪明了一样。
better. And you might walk out and say, oh my God, I manifested that. That is really actually a self-fulfilling prophecy. And if you want to see it in action, you've got to hear about this very famous experiment from the 1960s, you've probably heard about it before, but it was about how teachers' expectations of students actually determined their grades and the students who performed best. And it really came down to the students who wore glasses. Because the teachers assumed, you know, if you wear glasses, you're more intelligent. So they treated them as such. They treated them as if they were already intelligent.
因此，这创造了那个自我实现预言。这意味着他们给了他们更多的关注。这意味着他们给了他们更多的赞扬。这意味着他们花更多的时间陪伴他们，给了他们更具挑战性的工作。所以他们才是取得成就的人，这一切都归功于自我实现预言。你也可以把同样的公式用在自己身上。所以关于显化心理学的最后两点。我们倾向于认为我们思考的事物吸引了我们所经历的事物的另一个原因
And therefore, it created that self-fulfilling prophecy. It meant that they gave them more attention. It meant that they gave them more praise. It meant that they spent more time with them that gave them more challenging work. And so they were the ones who achieved, all because of a self-fulfilling prophecy. And you can use that same formula on yourself. So two final points on the psychology of manifestation. The other reason that we tend to think that what we think about attracts what we experience
也归结于显化发生的思维模式如何解锁成长型与固定型思维模式。因此，固定型思维模式假设我们的能力是天生且不可改变的，我们生来拥有的是什么就是什么。而且，你知道，如果我们懒惰，我们就是懒惰。如果我们不擅长运动，我们就是不擅长运动。如果我们不自律，我们就是不自律。成长型思维模式意味着我们相信所有人类，
also comes down to how the thought patterns that occur with manifestation unlock a growth versus a fixed mindset. So a fixed mindset assumes that our abilities are innate and unchangeable, that what we're born with is what we're given. And, you know, if we're lazy, we're lazy. If we're not good at sports, we're not good at sports. If we're not disciplined, we're not disciplined. A growth mindset means that we believe that all humans,
你和我都有改变的能力，我们是可以进步的。这意味着我们对学习、成长和成功能力的信念，我们的成长型思维模式可以，确实会影响我们是否能有效地显化我们所渴望的东西。重要的是，研究确实表明，如果我们真正相信自己能实现某事，我们就更愿意为之付出努力。所以通过对自己说所有那些积极的话来显化，通过说，这就是我真正想要的，这就是我是谁，这就是我要实现的。
you and I are capable of change and that we can improve. And that means that our beliefs about our ability to learn, grow, and succeed, our growth mindset can, that can indeed affect whether we effectively manifest what we desire. Importantly, the research really suggests that if we truly believe we can achieve something, we are more willing to do the hard work to achieve it. So manifesting by saying all those positive statements to yourself, by saying, this is what I really want, this is who I am, this is what I'm going to achieve.
这意味着我们内心愿意为此努力的部分更加被激活，我们更愿意成长以迎接挑战。最后，显化起作用的原因是我们所谓的积极情绪的向上螺旋。显化背后的思维过程实际上也附带地产生了一个重要的认知积极反馈循环，即我们思考积极美好的事情越多，我们实际上就越倾向于看到积极美好的事情，就像确认偏误一样。然后它又向前迈进了一步，这意味着由于所有这些美好的事情都在发生在我们身上，我们实际上通常对我们当前的状态更加乐观、有动力、快乐。我们可以看到周围所有这些美好的事情，因为我们一直，呃，
It means that the parts of ourselves that are willing to work for that are more activated, that we're more willing to grow into a challenge. And finally, the reason that manifestation works is what we call the upward spiral of positive emotions. So the thought process behind manifestation actually incidentally also creates an important cognitive positive feedback loop where the more we think positive good things, the more we actually tend to see positive good things like a confirmation bias. And then it goes a step further, which means that we actually are generally more optimistic, motivated, happy about our current state because all these good things are happening to us. we can see all these good things around us because we've been, uh,
被引导去看到这些事情，被启动去看到这些事情。当然，一个更快乐、更乐观的人会更有动力。因此，诸如吸引力法则或疏离法则之类的显化技术，它们之所以看似有效，是因为它们改变了我们对周围环境的感知
queued to see those things, prime to see those things. And of course, someone who is more happy, optimistic is going to be more motivated. So manifestation techniques like the law of attraction or the law of detachment, they really seemingly work because of how they transform the perception of our
、我们的自我信念，从而触发重要的目标、意向和激活行为。我想非常非常明确地指出，没有零证明显化本身起作用。有些人确实喜欢引用量子理论的观点，该理论指出宇宙中的一切都是由能量组成的。因此，当我们宣称一个意图并实践显化时，我们将我们的能量与宇宙的能量保持一致。但具体来说，我真的认为这归结于我们的行动。我想谈谈
circumstances, our self-beliefs and therefore trigger important goal, intentional and activating behaviors. I want to be really, really clear there is zero proof that manifestation works on its own. Some people do like to cite this idea of quantum theory, which states that everything in the universe is made up of energy. So when we declare an intention and we practice manifestation, we align our energy with the universe's energy. But specifically, I really think what it comes down to is our actions. And I want to talk about
我们如何在显化的帮助下，更好地激活重要的、激励性的、重要的、激励性的行为，并真正去追求我们想要的东西，当然是在这个短暂的休息之后。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身以及建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以努力工作。看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
how we can get better at activating, important, motivating, important, motivating, behaviors and actually going after what we want, with the help of manifestation, of course, after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to work. Look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。世界上令我们惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》。这就是在 I-Hart Radio 应用程序上的 T-W-O-Persent。Apple Podcasts，或无论你在哪里获取你的播客。还记得黛安·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at It 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔参加的节目，
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。然后你把那句话说完。是的。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，我们在追逐中陷入得太深，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，而我们仍在追逐它，我们不知道什么时候已经做够了，因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世时做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。在2023年，
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法院听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones.
这需要一大批互联网侦探。来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。
It took an army of internet detainees. to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·奥布莱恩。欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这还没结束。在 I-Heart radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 love-trapped 播客。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Amaricopa County as Laura O'Brien. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the I-Heart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我听过的关于显化的最有力的名言来自对斯坦福大学一位教授的采访。他的名字叫詹姆斯·多迪博士。这就是他真正想说的。显化不是要求宇宙奖赏你，而是重新布线你的大脑来奖赏它自己。我很喜欢这句话。当我第一次听到它时，绝对爱不释手。它真正描述的是能动性。我是这样看的。当我们的mind做好准备并确信我们会成功时，这就像是在一辆巨大的半挂卡车上转动方向盘。
So the most powerful quote I have ever heard about manifestation came from an interview with a professor at Stanford University. His name is Dr. James Doddy. And this is really what he had to say. manifestation is not about asking the universe to reward you, it's about rewiring your brain to reward itself. Love that quote. Absolutely loved when I heard it for the first time. And what's really describing is agency. This is how I see it. When our mind is on board and convinced of our success, it's kind of like turning the wheel in a huge semi-truck.
对吧。所以我们的积极想法转动方向盘，然后所有的车厢都在后面跟着。因此，一旦我们对我们的情况和我们的信念有了积极的评估，我们的信念就会随之改变。我们的态度就会随之改变。然后我们的雄心壮志和我们的行动就会随之而来。所以当你的思想和念头准备就绪时，你的行为和意图就会随之而来。认识到这一点至关重要，因为我们在这里追求的是一种真正平衡的方法，显化不仅仅是许愿。我们不希望它导致大量的，你知道的，不切实际的期望和指责。
Right. So our positive thoughts turn the wheel and then all the carriages follow behind it. So once we have a positive appraisal of our situation and of our beliefs, our beliefs will then shift. Our attitudes will then shift. Then our ambition and then our actions will follow. So when your mind and your thoughts are on board, your behaviours and intentions follow suit. And acknowledging this is really essential because we are, after a really balanced approach here, manifestation is not just about wishing. And we don't want it to lead to a lot of, you know, unrealistic expectations and blame.
你知道，坐在那里想：我在许愿某事。我太希望它发生了。而它没有实现。这意味着我一定做错了，或者我是个坏人，或者我不配拥有美好的事物，因为宇宙没有赐予我。绝对不是。这可能是因为你没有让你的行动随之进行。所以我想谈谈五种显化技术。
you know, sitting there being like, I'm wishing for something. I want it to happen so badly. And it's not coming true. And that means I must be doing it wrong or I'm a bad person or I don't deserve good things because the universe isn't giving them to me. Absolutely not. It may be because you're not allowing your actions to follow along. So I want to talk about five manifestation techniques.
它真的可以激发这种积极的重构，从而刺激改变。以及这如何能带给你梦想的生活。而其中最重要的一个，我真正想谈的第一个，我看到人们一直在使用并且我自己也在使用的，我最近在新的一年里一直在大量做这件事情，那就是剧本式日记或叙事勾勒。听起来很高大上，其实很简单。我想让你做的是写一篇非常详细的日记条目，就好像你渴望的任何事情都已经发生了一样。我希望你尽可能详细地写出来。我的意思是细节要多到过分。所以这个方法，我做了一些研究。它真正作为一种副产品出现
It can really inspire that positive restructuring and therefore spur on change. And how that can bring about your dream life. and the biggest one, the first one I really want to speak about that I see people using all the time and that I actually personally use. I've just recently been doing this a lot with the new year is scripted journaling or narrative conjuring. Sounds fancy, it's actually really simple. What I want you to do is write out a very detailed journal entry as if whatever you are desiring has already happened. And I want you to write it out in as much detail. And I mean overkill with the detail. So this method, I did some research. It really emerged as an offshoot of
它真的能激发积极的重组，从而促进改变。以及这如何能带来你梦想的生活。最重要的一点，也是我最想谈论的第一点，我看到人们一直在使用，而且我自己也在使用。我最近在新年期间经常这样做，那就是剧本式日记或叙事幻想。听起来很花哨，其实非常简单。我想让你写一篇非常详细的日记，就好像你渴望的事情已经发生了一样。我希望你尽可能详细地写出来。我的意思是细节要极其丰富。所以这个方法，我做了一些研究。它确实作为一个分支出现于
this 1970s kind of project to do with neurolinguistic programming. So boring. But basically, this project encouraged individuals as part of this process to visualize their futures using all five senses. And basically what they found was that when we thought about our future using words and actions and then using all these different sensory inputs, our subconscious perception of the world changed and ultimately determined what we believed was possible for us to attain, achieve, and attract. So that project kind of like came across this incidentally. And I'll give you an example of how you can use scripted journaling in your own life. Say you are really trying to manifest a huge lifestyle change or overhaul. So you want to make yourself into someone who is
这个20世纪70年代的项目与神经语言程序学有关。听起来很无聊。但基本上，这个项目鼓励个人在这一过程中用全部五种感官来想象自己的未来。他们基本上发现，当我们用言语、行动然后用所有这些不同的感官输入来思考我们的未来时，我们对世界的潜意识感知就会改变，并最终决定了我们认为自己有可能获得、实现和吸引的东西。所以那个项目有点像偶然遇到了这个。我将举例说明如何在自己的生活中使用剧本式写日记。假设你真的在努力实现巨大的生活方式改变或彻底改变。所以你想把自己塑造成这样一个人：
active who has a large group of friends who will boost each other up who goes on hikes goes to Pilates whatever it is get out your journal get out a pen and write a journal entry that sounds like today i woke up in my beautiful linen sheets and the sun was shining through my apartment window and that apartment looked down onto 49th street and i'd bought it a couple months ago and i decided that i would text my friend group to go to Pilates with each other and this was what the picture for my friend's group looked like and this was what we called the group chat name and this is how many people were in that group chat and I put on this outfit that was this color from this brand and I ate this for breakfast and these were the ingredients and this is how it tasted and this is what my carpet looks like and these
充满活力，有一大群能互相鼓励的朋友，去远足，去练普拉提，不管是什么，拿出你的日记本，拿出一支笔，写一篇日记，听起来像是：今天我在美丽的亚麻床单上醒来，阳光透过我公寓的窗户照进来，那个公寓俯瞰着49街，我在几个月前买下了它，我决定发信息给我的朋友圈一起去普拉提，这就是我朋友群体的照片的样子，这就是我们群聊的名字，这就是那个群聊里的人数，我穿了一件这个品牌这个颜色的衣服，我早餐吃了这个，这些是配料，这就是它的味道，这就是我的地毯的样子，这些是
are my steps down to the street and you know this is what the polario studio looked like this is the perfume that my friend was wearing she smiled when she saw me every little detail I feel like you get the picture as much as possible if writing isn't really your thing you can also use an audio journal where you describe your perfect work day at your dream job or an amazing date you're yet to go on but that you know is in the future you know with as much detail as possible that scripting doesn't just have to be you know written down you can also make it verbal that can be really really powerful and the reason that it's powerful is because it gets you to think about aspects of your goal or your dream that you might not consider you know often when we set goals or when manifesting
通往街道的台阶，你知道，这就是那个普拉提工作室的样子，这是我朋友喷的香水，她看到我时笑了，每一个小细节，我觉得你大概能理解了，尽可能地多写，如果写作实在不是你的强项，你也可以使用语音日记，在其中描述你在理想工作中的完美工作日，或者一个你还没去过但你知道未来一定会经历的精彩约会，你知道，尽可能详细，这种剧本不一定非得是写下来的，你也可以把它说出来，这可以非常非常强大，之所以强大，是因为它能促使你去思考目标的某些方面，或者是你可能不会经常考虑的梦想，你知道，通常当我们设定目标或在具象化
something. We're so just focused on it happening, right? We're so focused on the future and the outcome. And we don't really have an idea of what we need to get there or timelines or small components or what needs to happen between then and now and what it could feel like. And the scripted writing in this narrative exercise gets us to fill in a lot of the blanks. And I'm going to get a little bit scientific here, but there was actually a series of studies conducted between 2008 and 2014. that examined what happened when we visualised future goals in this way, or we engage in positive thinking and writing or mentally simulating future events. And what it found was that two important brain areas are activated by exercises like this,
某事时。我们太专注于它发生了，对吧？我们太专注于未来和结果。我们其实并不知道我们需要什么才能到达那里，或者时间表、小组成员、当时和现在之间需要发生什么，以及它会是什么感觉。这种叙事练习中的剧本式写作促使我们填补了许多空白。我要讲得稍微科学一点，在2008年到2014年之间，其实进行了一系列研究。检验了当我们以这种方式想象未来目标时，或者当我们进行积极的思考和写作或在心理上模拟未来事件时会发生什么。研究发现，像这样的练习会激活两个重要的大脑区域，
the ventral medial prefrontal cortex and the posterior cingulate cortex, both of which, by the way, implicated in attention and self-reflection. But more specifically, these areas of the brain, support internally directed action. Basically, they are the parts of the brain that when a thought comes in, they say, okay, we're going to make this happen. How do we do this? What parts of our body do we need to put into action? What other thought processes in our brain do we need to switch on? Even if a visual or written script isn't your thing and you're more of a visual thinker or learner, you can also utilize the power of a good old-fashioned vision board. I'm sure you've all seen
腹内侧前额叶皮层和后扣带皮层，顺便说一句，这两个皮层都与注意力和自我反思有关。但更具体地说，这些大脑区域支持内部导向的行动。基本上，它们是这样的大脑部分：当一个想法涌现时，它们会说，好吧，我们要把这件事变成现实。我们该怎么做？我们需要让身体的哪些部分付诸行动？我们需要开启大脑中的哪些其他思维过程？即使视觉或文字剧本不是你的菜，而你更倾向于视觉思考者或学习者，你也可以利用老式梦想板的力量。我确信大家都见过
the videos of people sharing their vision boards from 2023 and how many surprising things from those boards actually happened. I really think it's because representing your goals visually in this way is such a great physical visual cue or reminder of what you are working towards. And therefore, when you have that more in your focus, you are more likely to remember, hey, I actually want this thing. What have I been doing to make it happen? Maybe I should be working. harder on that. There's a famous quote that you become what you behold or what you see, your environment and what you are visually exposed to. That really does influence mood, motivation, attitude. Vision board work actually works on a part of our brain called the
人们分享他们2023年梦想板的视频，以及那些梦想板上有多少令人惊讶的事情真的发生了。我真的认为这是因为以这种方式直观地展现你的目标，是一个极好的物理视觉线索或提醒，提醒你正在为什么努力。因此，当你把更多的注意力集中在这一点上时，你就更有可能记住，嘿，我其实想要这个东西。为了实现它我一直在做什么？也许我应该更努力地工作。有一个名言，你成为你所注视的或你所看到的，你的环境以及你所接触到的视觉事物。这确实会影响情绪、动力、态度。梦想板的工作实际上作用于我们大脑的一个部分，称为
reticular activating system RAS. It's actually located in the brain stem. It's a very essential part of our brain that filters information and determines what's important. And when you visualize your goals frequently as you do with the vision board. Your RAS becomes more attuned to opportunities that align with those goals. So this process really helps you notice things in your environment that can help you achieve your aspirations, making you more focused and intentional. So here's the thing that you really need to do, though, to make a vision board work for you. Don't just choose the photos that are available to you in a magazine or that you have lying
网状激活系统RAS。它实际上位于脑干中。它是我们大脑中非常重要的一个部分，负责过滤信息并决定什么是重要的。当你像使用梦想板那样频繁地可视化你的目标时。你的RAS就会变得更加敏锐，能够发现与这些目标一致的机会。因此，这个过程确实能帮助你注意到环境中能帮你实现抱负的事物，让你更加专注和有目标性。不过，要想让梦想板对你起作用，你真正需要做的是：不要只选择杂志上现成的或者随手放在那里的照片。
around. You really have to be intentional with setting this up. So choose the photos that most resonate with you. Choose to have a few options. And I really like to have four segments of my vision board. One segment is for career. One is for relationships. One is for lifestyle. One is for personal growth goals. So things like hobbies, travel, spiritual goals. And I really, really make sure that it's not all material things. There should be experiences on there too. There should be things that really activate my senses, things that are small and daily. And something that Mel Robbins actually said that was really powerful in a recent episode of hers is that you can't just have big life-changing goals on a vision board. This is more about the lifestyle that surrounds achieving those goals.
你在搭建这个时一定要有目的性。所以要选择那些最能引起你共鸣的照片。选择有几个选项。我真的很喜欢把我的梦想板分成四个部分。一部分用于职业。一个是人脉。一个是生活方式。一个是个人成长目标。比如爱好、旅行、精神目标。而且我真的、真的很确保不全是物质的东西。上面也应该有各种体验。应该有一些能真正激活我感官的东西，那些微小的、日常的事情。梅·罗宾斯（Mel Robbins）在她最近的一期节目中说过一句非常有力的话，那就是你不能只在梦想板上有改变生活的大目标。这更多的是关于围绕实现这些目标的生活方式。
You can't just have a picture of the finish line of, you know, the New York marathon without a few pictures of you running, you know, or of a training plan or of healthy fuel. your vision board needs to be focused on the building blocks as well as the big outcomes. Let's talk about another very well-known manifestation strategy or accompaniment, and that it's affirmations. This is probably the strategy that I rely on most heavily in my own life, mainly because I know that scientifically speaking how I talk to myself matters, also affirmations are so accessible on a daily basis. You know, vision boards, scriptural,
你不能只有一张纽约马拉松终点线的照片，却没有几张你奔跑的照片、训练计划的照片或健康能量的照片。你的梦想板不仅要关注宏大的结果，还要关注构成它们的基石。让我们来谈谈另一个广为人知的显化策略或配套方法，那就是肯定语。这可能是我在自己的生活中最深信不疑的策略，主要是因为我知道从科学的角度来看，我如何对自己说话至关重要，而且肯定语在日常生活中也非常容易实现。你知道，梦想板、剧本，
they're a real time commitment and a very worthy time commitment, not necessarily something that you can do every day, but affirmations you can even do a few times a day. And when I was going through a really transformative time, when I was 22, I had a list of 10 affirmations written on a big piece of paper on the inside of my bedroom door, and these affirmations were genuinely so important to me,
它们需要投入大量时间，而且是非常值得的时间投入，不一定是你每天都能做的事情，但肯定语你甚至每天可以做好几次。当我经历一个真正具有变革性的时期时，我22岁，我的卧室门内侧的一张大纸上写着10条肯定语，这些肯定语对我的意义真的太重大了，
and I really think that they were a huge, huge kind of, way in which I was able to lead a more fulfilling life compared to the life I was living before. And I actually went searching for these because I was like, these affirmations were really good. And it took me in a while to come up with them. Like it was a very finely tuned list. And finally, I found a picture in my phone of this list on the back of my door and I want to read these out to you. These were the affirmations I used to really help me bring about a more positive way of seeing my life. and therefore a more positive life.
而且我真的认为它们是非常、非常重要的一种方式，让我能够过上比以前更有意义的生活。我其实去找过这些，因为我觉得这些肯定语真的很好。我花了一段时间才想出它们。就像这是一个经过精心调校的清单。最后，我在手机里找到了一张贴在门背后的清单的照片，我想把它读给你们听。这些是我用来真正帮助自己建立更积极的生活观，进而建立更积极生活的肯定语。
I radiate confidence and self-assurance. I have an attractive aura. I am someone who goes after what I want. People feel good around me. I trust myself to make the right decisions. I am a powerful creator of my reality. I am a hard worker. I am constantly attracting incredible things into my life.
我散发着自信和笃定。我有一种吸引人的气场。我是那种追求自己想要的东西的人。人们和我在一起感觉很好。我相信自己能做出正确的决定。我是自己现实的强大创造者。我是个努力工作的人。我不断地将不可思议的事情吸引到我的生活中。
I release the need for others' approval. I am in control of my best and my worst thoughts. These were the affirmations that I would recite to myself every morning for over a year. And it was like putting on a mental armour every day. The first thing I said to myself in the morning was, I'm not stressed about the day, I'm not overwhelmed, I'm not worried about how I look. All of these natural thoughts were,
我释放了对他人认可的需求。我能掌控自己最好和最坏的想法。这些就是我每天早晨对默念了一年多的肯定语。这就像每天穿上精神铠甲一样。我早上对自己说的第一句话是，我对今天不感到压力，我不感到不知所措，我不担心自己的外表。所有这些自然而然的想法都会
would pop up and instead I would put myself into a place of self-empowerment by making sure I left my house every single morning with a more positive statement and positive feeling about myself in mind. And it really did change how I approach challenges, change how I approached people, how productive I was as well. I really think that it also changed how I made friends. Like there was this huge shift for me between being quite lonely. and then suddenly having all these people in my life because I was, I really think entering the outside world radiating positive energy because I felt good about myself. I also have affirmations that I use for specific circumstances. Before, you know, I mentioned a public speaking. I have
涌现出来，相反，我通过确保每天早晨离开家时，心里都怀着对自己的更积极的陈述和积极的感觉，让自己进入一个自我赋能的处境。这确实改变了我应对挑战的方式，改变了我接触人的方式，也改变了我的工作效率。我真的认为它也改变了我交朋友的方式。比如对我来说有一个巨大的转变，从相当孤独，到突然生活中有了所有这些人，因为我真的认为，我带着积极的能量进入外部世界，因为我对自我感觉良好。我也有用于特定情况的肯定语。以前，你知道的，我提到了公开演讲。我有
five affirmations for that in my notes up. Anytime I need to public speak. I say I am prepared for this. My voice is strong and steady. The people in this room will be captivated by me. I speak and communicate with ease and I am excited for the opportunity to share knowledge. Very, very effective. And if you want a fun psychology study that provides evidence for the effectiveness of this method, we can actually look at one from 2015 conducted at the University of Wisconsin, Madison, where 67 students were asked to either participate in an affirmation exercise before a task or not. And those who outperforms the other students, all of them were those who were those who were who had done affirmations because they felt more capable. And it's free. Like, that's the crazy
记事本上有五个关于这方面的肯定语。任何时候我需要公开演讲。我说我为此做好了准备。我的声音强劲而平稳。这个房间里的人都会被我吸引。我说话和交流都很轻松，而且我对分享知识的机会感到兴奋。非常、非常有效。如果你想要一个有趣的心理学研究来证明这种方法的有效性，我们实际上可以看看2015年在威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校进行的一项研究，当时有67名学生被要求在任务前参与肯定语练习，或者不参与。那些表现优于其他学生的学生，全部都是那些做过肯定语练习的人，因为他们觉得自己更有能力。而且它是免费的。听着，这才是最疯狂的部分。
part. You don't need to do some crazy thing. You just have to make your list and stick to it. Okay, before we talk about limitations, I want to talk about one final way to combine manifestation and psychology in your pursuit of your goals. And it's called a sensory anchor. And the sensory anchor we're going to be talking about today is music. So a sensory anchor is a stimulus such as a sound, smell, touch that triggers a specific emotional or mental state. Music in particular is highly effective because music is very emotional and it directly triggers a lot of emotional centres of the brain. It's why we get tingles when we listen to songs. It's why we have a physical reaction. It's why it evokes memories. By pairing music with your
你不需要做什么疯狂的事情。你只需要列出你的清单并坚持下去。好了，在我们讨论局限性之前，我想谈谈最后一种将显化和心理学结合起来追求目标的方法。它被称为感官锚点。我们今天要讨论的感官锚点是音乐。因此，感官锚点是一种刺激，例如声音、气味、触觉，它会触发特定的情绪或心理状态。音乐尤其有效，因为音乐极具情绪化，并且它直接触发大脑的许多情感中心。这就是为什么我们听歌时会有战栗感。这就是为什么我们会有身体反应。这就是为什么它能唤起回忆。通过将音乐与你的
visualization or manifestation practice, you can train your brain to associate certain songs or sounds with a mindset of success or confidence or joy. So what I want you to do is put together a playlist of songs that make you really like motivated, inspired, pumped up, feeling good about yourself, like alive. Make a playlist like that. And any time you are in the mindset, you're in the mood, you're in the place to achieve something to get shit done, or you're just feeling low as well, play that playlist. I've already seen so many examples of these on Spotify.
可视化或显化练习相结合，你可以训练你的大脑将某些歌曲或声音与成功、自信或快乐的心态联系起来。所以我想让你做的是，把一首首能让你真正感到有动力、受鼓舞、振奋、对自己感觉良好、充满活力的歌曲组合成一个播放列表。做一个这样的播放列表。每当你有这种心态、有这种心情、有这种状态去实现某事、去把事情搞定，或者当你感到沮丧时，播放那个播放列表。我已经看到Spotify上有太多这样的例子了。
Like you can look up manifestation playlist or mindset shift playlist, anything like that. And people have already curated music that is intended to evoke a really like excited, motivated, passionate, creative mindset. And I just want to say one final thing with all these methods, the thing that really links them and why they are implicated in the manifestation process, is that all of them in some way using, you know, writing, using your words, using what you see, using what you hear, all of them are influencing us to see outcomes is happening in our favor by influencing how we think about things. So before we conclude this episode, I really think that it would be remiss of me to not consider the limitations of manifestation. and the privilege that definitely comes with being able to implement things like scripting or affirmations
你可以查找显化播放列表或心态转变播放列表，诸如此类的。人们已经精心策划了旨在唤起一种非常兴奋、充满动力、充满激情、充满创意的心理状态的音乐。我只想最后说一件事，对于所有这些方法，真正将它们联系起来的原因以及它们为什么会参与到显化过程中的是，它们都在某种程度上利用了——你知道的，写作、使用你的言语、使用你所看到的、使用你所听到的，所有这些都在通过影响我们思考事物的方式，来影响我们看到结果对我们有利。所以在我们结束这一期节目之前，如果我不考虑显化的局限性，我真的认为这将是一种失职。
and see them as being effective, you know, manifesting that lifestyle that we want. If that's something that is really happening for people, we have to question why it's not happening for others. And let's be honest, a lot of the things that we want to manifest, they are luxuries. And we could not begin to be, you know, even dream of them, let alone receive them, receive first class flights, receive dream jobs, receive money, if our fundamental basic human needs weren't already met. So food, water, security, safety, health, emotional and social support, those are the fundamental foundations of human life. And so many people don't have those things.
以及能够实施诸如剧本或肯定语之类的东西所带来的特权，并认为它们是有效的，你知道的，显化我们想要的生活方式。如果这确实是人们正在发生的事情，我们必须质疑为什么它没有发生在其他人身上。老实说，我们想要显化的许多东西都是奢侈品。如果我们的基本人类需求还没有得到满足，我们就无法开始——你知道的，甚至梦想它们，更不用说接受它们了，接受头等舱航班，接受梦想的工作，接受金钱。所以食物、水、安全、健康、情感和社会支持，这些是人类生活的基本基础。而许多人并没有这些东西。
There are people in war zones or experiencing violence or poverty who may, be wishing harder than any of us than you and me for a life of peace, of safety, food and their bellies, and they're not receiving it. So I think that we also have to recognize that in order to manifest anything, you do actually have to have the ability to action your desires. And that means privilege and resources. You know, if we think that manifestation is just this immaterial, energetic quantum force at work, why is the quantum force not helping so many people who are really doing it hard? Why does the universe's energy seem to neglect people that are struggling in poverty or that are less privileged than us? Because I don't think that's how energy works.
有些人身处战区或经历暴力或贫困，他们可能比我们任何人——比你和我——更强烈地渴望和平、安全、能填饱肚子的食物的生活，但他们却没有得到。所以我也认为，为了显化任何事情，你实际上必须具备将你的愿望付诸行动的能力。这意味着特权和资源。你知道的，如果我们认为显化只是一种非物质的、运作中的量子能量力量，为什么量子力量没有帮助那些真正生活艰难的许多人呢？为什么宇宙的能量似乎忽视了在贫困中挣扎的人或不如我们有特权的人？因为我不认为能量是这样运作的。
You know, if the quantum theory is positive energy, attracts positive energy, like, it's forgetting about a large group of people. So it is a privilege to be able to use psychological methods of manifestation to really bridge the gap between intention and motivation and therefore achievement. And I think that before we go out there and say, yeah, just manifest it. Like, just think positive things and good things will happen. You've got to remember that that's not the case for everyone and that it is really a blessing and something you should be grateful for that this is a technique that you are exploring and that could work for you. So I find that when I think about manifestation as an exercise that is rooted in self-belief,
你知道，如果量子理论是正能量吸引正能量，那么，它就遗忘了一大群人。因此，能够利用显化的心理学方法来真正弥合意图与动机之间、进而与成就之间的差距，是一种特权。我认为在我们出去说“是的，只要去显化它。就像，只要想积极的事情，好事就会发生”之前，你必须记住，并非对所有人都是如此，而且这是一项你正在探索且可能对你起作用的技术，这真的是一种祝福，你应该对此心怀感激。所以我发现，当我把显化看作是一种植根于自信、心理学的练习时，
psychology, and then having the ability to take actions based on your positive thinking, that makes a lot more sense to me and that's something that, yeah, again, I think we should be grateful for. So I really hope that you learnt something from this episode. You learned something about the science, from the studies, about the research, the constant, that make up manifestation is such a powerful method of attraction or of detachment, whichever one you choose to believe in. If there's something I missed here, I would love to hear from you.
心理学，然后有能力根据你的积极思考采取行动，这对我来说更有意义，这也是我觉得——是的，再次，我认为我们应该心怀感激的事情。所以我真的希望你从这期节目中学到了一些东西。你从研究中了解到了科学，了解到了研究，了解到了构成显化作为一种强大的吸引力或分离方法（无论你选择相信哪一种）的常数。如果有什么我漏掉的，我很想听听你的意见。
Please share your manifestation exercises that you use. I would love to hear from them. I would love to hear them, sorry, and love to hear from you because there's so many out there that I probably haven't mentioned that people could learn a lot from. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure you share it with a friend, share it with family member, show with your partner, someone who you think could learn as well. We are always open to episode suggestions. You just have to DM me on Instagram. That is how we get so many ideas for the psychology of your 20s.
请分享你使用的显化练习。我很想听听。抱歉，我很想听听它们的介绍，也很想听听大家的意见，因为外面有太多我可能没有提到过的练习，大家可以从中学到很多东西。如果你喜欢这期节目，请务必把它分享给朋友，分享给家人，展示给你的伴侣，或者任何你认为也能从中学习的人。我们随时欢迎节目建议。你只需在Instagram上给我发私信。这就是我们为“20多岁心理学”获得如此多灵感的途径。
And make sure you're following along. Make sure you're subscribed. Make sure you follow us over there on Instagram. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the state. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
确保你一直在关注。确保你已订阅。确保你在Instagram上关注我们。直到下一次，注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是选择走楼梯的人数。当也有自动扶梯可用时。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app,
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-HeartRadio应用上的TWA%，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on The Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode we pick a year unpack what went down
Apple Podcasts，或任何你收听播客的地方。在《回顾一下》（Look Back at it）播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我来说很大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么
And try to make sense of how we survived it With our friends, fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s 84 was a wild year I don't think there's a more important year For black people Listen to Look Back at it
并试着理解我们是如何活过来的，和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人更重要。收听《回顾一下》
On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难的学习》（Learn the Hardway），主持人是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方都真的不太安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听《艰难的学习》
I-Hard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army
I-Hard广播应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生了双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是个骗局。你对某人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批
of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的经历。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑爆炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人。该集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。